scottish first minister nicola sturgeon
says updated guidance about christmas
will be issued
later today and the welsh first minister
mark drakeford has been explaining why
he's concluded
that a smaller christmas is a safer
christmas
the advice of the welsh government is
that only two households should come
together
to form an exclusive christmas bubble
during
the five-day period the fewer people we
mix with in our own homes
the less chance we have of catching or
spreading
the virus nobody wants to be ill
at christmas and none of us
want to give this deadly disease
to our closest family or friends
we don't intend to take away the
flexibility
that in my view wouldn't be fair at this
stage
and it wouldn't be realistic either and
indeed it may risk undermining rather
than strengthening compliance with the
overall
covert guidance however we
and scottish government do intend to
strengthen the guidance we give to
people about whether and how they should
make
use of the flexibility the guidance in
scotland is already a bit tighter
than elsewhere but we hope we can come
to a four nations agreement on a clear
and united message to the public
in a moment we'll speak to james
matthews in edinburgh first let's go to
westminster and our political
correspondent
tom rayner tom the prime minister said
there was four nations agreement
on this it doesn't really feel like it
at the moment does it
well certainly from what boris johnson
said at prime minister's questions
you're right it was
uh conveyed as though the result of
talks that have been going on chaired by
michael gove
with the devolved administrations that
started yesterday and concluded this
morning
had arrived at a position uh where they
had unanimous
unanimously agreed not to change the law
when it comes to the christmas
regulations now of course
that is the case it seems there has been
agreement not to change
the letter of the law but what we are
seeing from
what you heard there from mark drakeford
and indeed nicholas sturgeon is that the
spirit of the law if you like
uh does appear to be an area uh where
the four parts of the uk
are diverging somewhat mark drapeford
saying that he wants to see
households of two be the main bubble
in terms of the relaxations over
christmas period rather than three now
that's guidance it's advice it means
that if you're in wales
and you meet in a group of three
households you are not breaking
the law but what you are doing is going
against the advice of the welsh
government
and clearly this distinction is
important because
uh the law is set in westminster but
clearly the devolved administrations
have powers when it comes to public
health advice and public health
guidance uh to operate in their own way
and clearly mark drakeford is deciding
uh that he will do that now we know that
the prime minister is going to hold a
news conference at some point
this afternoon the time yet to be
confirmed alongside the
chief medical officer chris whittie and
so there will be big questions for boris
johnson
about whether or not there will be
changes to the government advice with
regards to
england even if the law itself doesn't
change and certainly from the tone boris
johnson struck
sarah in prime minister's questions it
would seem that it
doesn't look likely that boris johnson
will be particularly
uh inclined towards changing the
guidance specifically
uh but perhaps what we will see is the
messaging uh
intensified uh lots of suggestions we
heard it from robert jenwick
uh the community secretary on sky news
this morning about people taking uh
personal responsibility using their
judgment
is it really necessary to use the full
five days is it really necessary
to see an elderly relative could you
wait till easter
that kind of persuasive attempt to make
people take responsibility
may be the direction that the government
takes with regards to england but
clearly
it is already at odds with the much more
straightforward and sober guidance that
the welsh government and the scottish
government
seem to be prepared to put out tom
westminster thank you to edinburgh
and james the guidance from the scottish
government
also tougher than the law
the guidance up here is uh broadly
similar
in terms of the principles they are on a
similar track to the rest of the united
kingdom
but there is that flexibility uh sarah
yes slightly tougher
uh i'm being told that it will not
change
in terms of the substance nicola
sturgeon at our covert briefing was
speaking about
strength and guidance the in practical
terms
i don't expect that to change it will be
you know eight members three households
five days over christmas
the guidance that will be underpinned in
due course will be luke
think hard about whether or not you need
to be together and don't regard
these maximums as targets so don't
regard five days
as five days you should spend together
she said try and spend
one together try and avoid overnight
stays in terms of
interaction make that outdoors if at all
possible and don't regard eight people
being together
as your target try and uh get somewhere
far less than that so
i expect we'll hear possibly over the
course of today
uh that that guidance will be
strengthened sarah but like i say
i don't expect it to change not today at
any rate nicola sturgeon
did leave a get out she was asked well
could it change between now
and the christmas period and she made it
clear that there was
that possibility should surrounding
circumstances be any different
in due course james in edinburgh thank
you